hello everybody it's me jake and this is
to Jake this of Jake's johansson podcast
how about that univ at you do that hey
there's no way that you're listening to
this by accident in fact I've got a
feeling you might be listening to it on
purpose because my guest this week is
the great Jimmy Pardo and Jimmy and I
are new friends but we're off we're off
to a good start and before I get to the
conversation though I do like to say
where I'm going that Jimmy is from
Chicago and so he started his comedy
career in Chicago I didn't get
autobiographical with him too much but
we got into it a little bit about
origins and starting offs and i'm going
to chicago this week that's why bring it
up ladies and gentlemen come see me at
zanies in chicago November fifth and
sixth and say knees in rosemont november
seventh then come up then drive up to
milwaukee when you're done with that the
friday after thanksgiving november 27
then fly out to Los Angeles November 28
for that Saturday night because I've got
a show to Hollywood improv and then
December 2 through 5 i'm in portland
oregon at helium helium comedy club
helium comedy club I can talk I've done
it for years December 10 through 12 I'm
in Indianapolis at morty's and December
17 to 20 i'm back here in california
improv anyway that is those are the
places that's where I'm going those are
some things that I'm doing I do other
things the shows only take a little bit
of my day and then the rest of the day
well of course I'm writing new material
obviously you've got to come up with new
things to tell people otherwise they get
tired of you and that's the last thing
that I want to happen for you people to
get tired of me so what do we got we've
got Jimmy Pardo this week he's the host
of the great podcast never not funny did
i mention that i may have i'm a little
frazzled I'm Fras I've gotta I've gotta
I gotta go check in for my flight online
after this while you listen to this
conversation so please enjoy I Klate
when you listen to this you'd be
surprised that I can't remember the name
of Jimmy's podcast because I just told
it to you but keep in mind that this
happened after that which and that's
welcome welcome to show business welcome
to the internet welcome to podcasting it
may not even be 2015 where you are but
if it's not let me just tell you 2015
was great but you know that cuz this is
after then unless you were born after
that in which case this has been around
longer than I thought all right here we
go Jimmy Pardo
things go wrong in your gut that can be
big problem she's not doing problems
yeah confected mood that's where that's
what that's supposed to say that says
yeah the happiness begins right in the
gut he had says dr. williams dr david
williams yeah also known as AKA dr
alternatives oh reallys got a nickname
yeah so that he had that kind of I've
been listening to him in his nonsense
for years on the advice of a another
comedian friend you know that's where
that's I think that's where we get our
best advice is your mother's right but
we're all nuts oh yeah if that's not bad
advice is it like if you if some nutjob
comic it has a piece of advice wouldn't
you listen to it cuz we're all kind of
nuts I think first of all I think we're
all kind of nuts in second of all I
think we're all sort of on the job of
trying to figure out how to control it
harnesses or yes or at least compensate
for it what do they call it when you're
when you're an alcoholic
high-functioning we're all trying to be
high functioning right yes with our
issue now let me ask you a couple of
questions ok have we started yeah well I
don't know how your program works I
apologize i've done no research cuz im
an [ __ ] that's perfect that's bad
that's but i had only been able to
research your show a little bit before I
went on it yeah that's good that was
because you were uh cheap skate no you
you had heard I spoke about you at the
very Mantlo concerts and you wanted to
hear it to first hand what I said about
you so it was really a self-serving why
you listen to my show well someone
tweeted me about that but I don't think
that's the only what sucks about it
mmm-hmm I can't I can't go back and
piece it all back together now that well
I can I remember a friend remember
everything's we met for the first time
at pod fest two years ago that's right
at mark marriage program which is kind
of ridiculous because I've been hearing
about you for along 20 years well yeah
in the comedy club you know who's a nice
guy you know this guy who you would like
jimmy pardo I know right mm-hmm
and it would go they would say the same
thing to me about Bill Hicks and then
eventually your name came up I met that
once bill died I literally could not
pull another neighborhood Bill Hicks
like cuz bill wasn't known as a nice guy
he was gonna know and that would have
been so long ago I would have been
surprised that yeah or even telling you
that I alluded my brain did Jimmy part
of the fastest minded comedy other
people's words not mine that's what
people do say couldn't think of
anybody's neighborhood Bill Hicks as a
nice guy so I'm disappointed with what I
had just said would you like to think
about who some other nice guys are that
you know Regan's a great guy he's a
great guy but I don't know him that well
you don't know Brian recall I know him
but I don't know him that well we've
done a few cakes together he actually I
were we well we worked together when he
was a feature a million years ago and
you were headlining yes it was a tough
week for me oh Jesus because he's very
good he was just his way up he was just
on his way up to blast out and it was
like okay I'll take this gift maybe he
took it because he wanted to hang out
with me for the weekend or whatever but
but it was like he was so good then I'd
have to go on and it would be me kind of
like yes I know he was terrific but
that's finished now that's known it's me
I'm doing my thing and this is what
that's like I remember watching his
special that pair of jokers with his
brother which was like 90 or 91 and
thinking he was great then and to think
that he was just a feature act is like
are you kidding everybody was a feature
act at some point but yeah even I mean
but II but he's been good forever yes I
guess I yeah he was great then I've
never seen him be like oh this guy
starting out but he's gonna be go places
it was like no we need step aside let
that I'd let him do his thing I worked
with him I did a week at the improv in
vegas and i watched every show as i do
any great comic yeah and it was amazing
that from you know please welcome Brian
Regan at the N in Regan to him and the
eye and goodbye when he's done I've
never seen anybody kill like that
consistently the entire week and we've
seen you and I a gazillion great comics
and do you think he's is he is he one of
those kind of technicians where he puts
together it's like the Rube Goldberg
device he puts together and then it
works every time I think
it's an intricate it's like a watch yeah
yeah now it had a little more randomness
of my show not that it's not good but
well that's that I saw at the Barry
Manilow show was phenomenal that's right
the berry man it was a good show coming
back to me it was good it was it's not
easy to be the opening person and the
reason that I was on that show i think
is because uh Barry wanted he he wanted
to go on after was dark but that's too
late for him to tell his fans look the
show starts at nine o'clock they'd be
like well we're not going that's too
late so you put a guy he put a guy you
tell him the show starts at eight-thirty
you put a guy on to do stand-up and then
you go on when it's dark that's how he
likes to do it well did it and it worked
out okay I enjoyed it they were well
mannered crowds it was as I as I said on
my show when you were on I've never seen
that go well and you it went well for
you it's because usually the audience
ignores you as the comic opening up for
an artery but you do that a lot right
I've done it a few times but no I
wouldn't say a lot I wouldn't say a lot
I think for me it's I'm i took that gig
just because who doesn't want to say
that they opened for Barry Manilow and
then I had done a few and it went well
so then the one that you saw was a was a
went well so we're having you come back
okay but at the Greek Theatre yeah
beautiful venue I got to be I get to be
on stage at the Greek Theatre three
nights I know right so I'm not bill burr
I'm not gonna be hella I'm not gonna be
I don't let's hate to be pessimistic but
I just I think it's safe to say that I'm
not gonna be selling out Madison Square
Garden is bill burr doing that or is he
selling out the theater at madison
square garden okay I didn't know there
was a technicality possible I didn't
know there was a way I could be wrong
too I could be wrong but I didn't think
he was doing the the Kevin Hart Dane
Cook thing oh ok but I maybe you're
right maybe I didn't realize there was
another cutter and that there was
another thing called Madison Square
Garden I love that there is I love that
there's I want there to even be a
smaller room so that i can do that you
would like a short i'm playing i'm doing
Madison I'm doing three school shoot
three shows at Madison Square Garden
it's the ticket booth oh yeah good for
you off night and that just 10 people
can get in there so we do three shows
mm-hmm everybody's happy I see all my
fans I didn't it's great goes
wonderfully I could be
on by the way I could be wrong so and in
fact i'm basing that on information that
was just given to me because i just i
like you said you know holy crap but
purse to a medicine square garden and
then that person corrected me and i
haven't done any research to make sure
that guy so I'm business on some guy
saying to me no it's just a theater well
that's podcasting isn't it yes me to me
that's it to two people who don't know
what they're talking about well that's
talking about some point how that's why
their life listen yes driving around in
their cars I mean this is my dream to
have people driving around in the car
listening to me now it's come true it's
a dreams really do happen not the
drinking yeah now Jade did I tell you
that I saw you at Letterman lives that
ever tell you that that in 2002 January
of 2002 could have been early februari
and he went to a taping of the show I
was there shooting my half-hour special
for Comedy Central and Eddie brill uh I
contacted Eddie and said hey I'm going
to be in town any chance I can come and
see Letterman he of course laughed in my
face over the phone about they do nobody
gets to how we dig like to give and not
only do they not like to to give favori
guest seats to people they especially
don't like people in show business to be
there day it was I you were not using
your seats whatever to whatever he's not
he put you so he said I'm he goes you
know Jake's not using his all that use
Jake's Heather and so I figured who the
lead guest was but you were doing
standing up comedy that week that nights
it was saying yeah it's always me that
I'm always doing that on that show
standing up I think was all about a
garage sale is that possible that would
have been a long time of 2002 yeah 2002
was a long time ago now isn't it's 13
years ago yeah doesn't yeah then we went
over inside the 911 site we saw ground
zero mm-hmm so we had a nice day it's
real nice day sounds like a really trip
to the big city yeah man well I'm a
little derailed about what were we gonna
talk about this you shall I know you're
on my show you don't do any research so
for all you know this is how it goes I I
don't know that it's not you're exactly
right yeah so it's good it's not no well
no this is kind of how it what
usually what do you usually do I'll
usually I get in here and I talked to
whoever shows up about what so you know
you like to try and talk about what's
going on or what's going on in their
life or I think an interesting thing
about you is that you and I were doing
the same kind of career which is going
on the road doing live performance and
comedy clubs for a while you were doing
that for quite a while before you kind
of left that and kind of became more
la-based and started your podcast and
all that well yeah but I but I still I
still hit the road from time to time
yeah but I but and I firstly I
appreciate the comparison with you I was
doing it more as a nobody and you were
doing it as a like a special event you
were doing it as you know for you know
it's 27 Letterman's under his belt here
comes Jake Johansen it's nice that you
would make that distinction but I this
is the thing that I like to talk about
is you know people's definition of
success in show business because I think
22 people who are just kind of regular
people who watch a few comedians on TV
maybe they know who somebody is but
they've been to them the difference
between you and high on the road in a
comedy club it's two guys who were on
the road who wish that they had their
own TV show or okay they were movie
stone yeah that would have been a fun
thing to do but I feel like it was it's
been a fun I enjoyed I enjoy doing clubs
do you still enjoy doing it do i still
enjoy doing clubs you know what I'm
gonna quote unquote the great Dan
Fogelberg God rest his soul in that song
go holding same auld lang syne where you
know he says the audiences are having
labored the traveling as hell I can't
stand it I cannot stand getting up going
to the airport all the BS but I know
it's cliched but the hour on stage I
love I like the part where I'm on the
plane and no one can call me and I can
just read well a book or watch you know
sometimes you get on those planes where
they've got the they think TV screen
yeah I a hundred percent agree with that
except now they have Wi-Fi on the plane
and because I want to play words with
friends whatever i'm on there so now i'm
getting my emails while i'm on the plane
and I wish I wasn't I I'm with you I did
love the idea of you you get on the
plane and you shut down for four hours
and you don't have to worry about
anything I agree that's what I I don't
like the Wi-Fi for that reason and then
when they talk about people being able
to talk on the phone on plane home day
the day that happens there's three
people are gonna get murdered that day
that day where the Sun Goes Down three
copy murder this would be awful right
yeah it's I already don't I don't like
it when they land and they say you can
turn your cell phone on the guys I hire
you at the baggage claim i'm on the
plane when i get to the baggage claim
i'll see you because i'm on them it's
like hey that's gonna happen in 10
minutes and you're a foot from my head
it's i have you heard the yeah it's a
character on the baba Tom radio show the
guy that does Donny Baker also does I'm
gonna get the name wrong but it's like
Bobby tarmac or something and he
basically is a eat that guy he doesn't
care of that who's got to get on the
phone a big shooter good as I just
landed atl gonna be heading over to our
Dean and it's it's that guy that loves
to talk about the airport and how it
just landed and and it's a really funny
character but it is that guy to a tee
yeah i just-i can't-- already can't take
that imagine heritage chicago the guy
next she was on the phone could you
imagine how horrible that's gonna be i
did have this happen years ago when they
had those phones that you could swipe
your credit card in yes it was some
douchebag lawyer who was no doubt on
somebody else's dime talking into that
credit card phone the whole flight to
about ridiculous court case you know
I'll tell you I I was up for a show on
Game Show Network in 19 let's call it 98
mm-hmm and I was on a flight I remember
I was in the middle seat flying
somewhere and we were supposed to hear
that day if I got the job so I can't
just you're dreaming to get out of that
middle I just want the aisle or the
window Jake uh but I remember putting
and I was broke I literally had no money
but I I'm not joking every let's call it
20 minutes I would put my credit card
through there and call my agent we hear
anything yet no well here's at some
point today okay
click sitting sitting sitting credit
card and then the bill came and it was
like I was already bad shape financially
you needed to get to show to make those
calls which I did not get yeah I did not
get the show I forget one was even
called but I know it was between it was
a jot you know John bizarre the comedian
John bizarre yes it was it was either
gonna be me and John bizarre hosting it
or the two guys they chose and they
chose the other two guys two guys named
Matt don't memorize names Madden the
other man you do remember their other
night or not you don't know I ok no I
see I'm not very good at children were
you say you don't and then you nod your
head up and down good so you don't you
don't I do not know yeah hmm John
bizarre bana where is he now I had a I
had such a fun gig with him he's a fun
guy he's a great guy and a funny guy but
it's an answer I don't know we used we
had the same agent and manager for a
while but I have no idea he may still
live in the valley as far as I know he
liked to go to Amsterdam did you know
that about him and Taiwan maybe as well
yeah it was that type of it wasn't the
pot thing it wasn't for the pot though
was not it was for the other thing that
the other things are very popular than
those two lands he had a wooden shoes he
looks footwear yeah did you see this big
into that Jake the dsw I'll put on a
press release yesterday that they will
not be opening at 6pm on Thanksgiving so
don't even think about buying shoes the
Christmas gift a day early Jake you know
I'm glad that you brought this up but
every through I am because this is it
that it's another thing I feel like this
is goes into the list of things that
sort of are upsetting to me okay I feel
like you get thanks get what do you get
you get thanksgiving kind of christmas
and kind of New Year's Day where things
are just shut down that's it like you
have to stay home and deal with the life
that you've made for yourself you know
and I feel like it's not asking too much
that those three days a year you just
stay home and you kind of try and work
it out with those people but but man
people can't do it's like we need to go
shopping that's what we need to do it
that's what we got to get back at that's
what people are like you have had a day
off I gotta go
I shopping I gotta do it now I gotta do
now ghetto relieved by Thanksgiving meal
to go by you can buy things on the
internet all the time do it right now
that amazon com I don't I don't know
about it's ruined my life it's that knee
bay Oh see I haven't got into ebay yet
what do you mean moving yet it's 2015 I
know but you gotta deal with a stranger
I like amazon.com because I've trust
that Jeff bezos's on top in between I
like him in between all these in Iraq
you like that you like in the river I
can't even say enter I can trust him
interment give me the word Jacob padder
intermediary thank you couldn't say it
my mouth wouldn't allow it hind up on
coke zero you can put me on speed dial
that I can do this for you you just call
me up and start giving me hints I think
would be me that's probably a wise thing
to do yeah it could be a segment could
be a regular segment that I have on your
show I never come on as a guest anymore
you just call me up and I guess words
that you can't think about the way I'm
great with all of that specifically
you're not coming out anymore that would
that's not only been on one time which
is ridiculous I should probably come on
again before he got on me are you
available tomorrow I can't do it
tomorrow I've already turned down a
dental appointment tomorrow oh no where
are you going tomorrow I've got well
I've got a friend is coming over here
Greg parents is coming over here because
I'm P and he I'm helping him with his
show let me ask you a question go ahead
is there any better human being on the
planet in greg behrendt i think you're a
nice person that Brian Regan is great oh
Jesus boy you Greg just got bumped onto
third no I wouldn't put him third but
well no I shouldn't say that sorry that
didn't come out right wait a minute ya
know it rings that Greg is a really
great guy I love I like my there are
there are so there's certain people in
this business that I just think are
great people and I did have not known
you until recently and I'm and I'm
grateful for that friendship now this is
the beginning we're still in the
beginning stay in two years but we're
going we're taking it slow I they always
say to do it's the best way to go right
you don't want to jump in or a
Kardashian listening you don't want to
want to leap into something realizes a
mistake this is never going sexual
that's what I'm saying you don't know
that in this creepy room that we're in
there's anything could happen in this
room and I wouldn't put a passion for
looks like a Mardi Gras knocks it under
some no I can't believe how the first
person who said it looks like the place
it like it looks like a serial killer
sure looks like the inside of your brain
and to you the inside of my brain looks
like a serial killer who I can
kill somebody I don't know what says to
you that I'm gonna kill somebody it just
looks like whatever like you watch it
travel guitar that's a regular guitar
you understand what boy I understand
what those two things are you struck I
mean come on but it's what do you see in
here that's that tells you it just died
it looks that doesn't look safe that
doesn't look up to code that's a power
strip it's got a yeah it's gonna if they
made all if this was a communist country
all of our all of our power adapters you
know the thing that they would all be
the same size and shape I mean maybe not
if it was a communist country maybe if
we had any sense how come I got to buy a
new power adapter every time I get a new
thing or you or the thing like we got a
vacuum cleaner that's got a battery that
has to be recharged wait while we got
the Hoover yeah you got the cordless
Hoover vacuum yeah do you want to see it
no I have it it's the great to make sure
that your we're talking about the same
one but you know why I bought it cuz i
went online cuz i was looking at the
dyson which is basically that's a guy
who found a way to make you watch people
vacuum I mean but the reviews are
horrible yeah and it's super expensive
and then i can so i got the hoover
because of the reviews because I trust
that Jeff Bezos I don't know whether you
in this Amazon are their sponsors that
why this is happening no I don't have
any sponsors I don't need I don't owe
anything to anybody a little itchy that
happens in here something I don't know
if I'm gonna get licensed ear I don't
know what kind of you know mold is
growing in here ah it's good for your
immune system that's what I'll tell you
about this room how could that be
possible because it's a challenge it's
like a workout you know you can't just
have your immune system be on a cruise
all the time you know what happens when
you're on a cruise you gain weight and
your skin goes weird you get a little
suicidal and but not in here in here you
oh no I'm just at all time no one here
i'm not sure thought of as i'm gonna be
murdered by you in any given moment by
any buy any item in this room can murder
me any item at all specifically this
dangling wire a pinata that you have
opening yeah not to worry about that i
bought the hoover and III this is
obviously it's fun to vacuum with it
it's makes it three thousand times
easier no it's not the same one oh yeah
we'll see this one it has this battery
that comes out and then it gets charged
up in the in the little thing and then
the little thing goes on the fritz
so I got to go on at first I tried to
sorry I tried to take it apart I'm a guy
who will take take it apart to see just
to see if there's some kind of something
in there that's obviously disconnected I
got to know which one you have now
because that is not the same one as me
take you in to see uh when we're done
here you'll show me the vacuum it's
gonna happen hey God you will it's gonna
happen you will your wife be okay with
that yeah she loves that thing she's a
little sad that the so the battery went
dead i went to charge it up but the
charge didn't work i took the charger
part i couldn't figure it out so now
I've had to order another charger give
the two batteries reruns in the unit
while this one charges we just have the
10 in another day you know what we were
doing Jimmy and this is this commentary
on myself and my wife but we were just
the housekeeper cleaner helper person
mm-hmm you know we're grown man now we
don't have to clean our own houses thank
God or at least our villain bathrooms so
she comes that helper person comes every
other week and so we just would not
vacuum until she'd come back just like
out of spite like to show her that's
your other this we're having a grudge
thing with my wife Oh each other who's
vacuuming it's me know there's gonna be
Donnie I'm making that name up i don't
know that your husband resins my wife no
i'm saying it's between belinda and I my
wife right but let's make housekeeper
clean is what i was saying i'm not gonna
do it you're not gonna do it there's
gonna be a little tension here wait for
her to show up plus wants to get out
that big now I sound like an ad who
wants to get out that big vacuum cleaner
Jimmy and drag it around and plug it in
I don't have time for that in my life
I'm a busy person but to get at this
little Hoover piece of cake right here
you get any turn it on how about is it
like vacuuming it's so do i how's it now
than curling better than curling on TV
you tell curling in the sport of Korea
the curve all vacuum was much better
than the right and vacuuming is not even
a sport could be yeah the way I do it
around my house yeah let me ask you a
question a very sir says it would you
weigh the bag at the end or is it just
the mileage that you I don't think you
gotta really get stirred away the bag
because no unless you're putting in the
same amount of dust in front of every
vacuum yeah but you can't go by the
mileage either because good vacuuming
requires that you spend a little time
going over an area like to deep clean
yeah like to go back and forth yeah I
mean let's say you put that vacuum
cleaner in front of one of these so
where do they come from the guys who run
the marathon
over in Africa that Zimbabwe no no
that's not it its leaves I come from
Kenya snappa lose we were looking for
Kenya boy I'm still wrong getting to the
bottom of why didn't get this game show
thing you don't throw the answers when
you're hosting oh yeah you're right I
guess you're right uh unless you're Alex
Trebek he doesn't know but he acts like
you know real good time anyway uh how
longs it take you and I'm very serious
because this is I'd make fun of myself
with this new cordless vacuum I will now
go all vacuum and I go and get it and I
and I'm vacuuming but yeah you're not
kidding when i used to have to pull it
out and literally take the what Oh point
four seconds to plug it in hmm seems
like a lot of hassle let's call it a
minute seems like a lot a minute but
it's not even a minute it's it's not
even a minute ma'am maybe it's a minute
by the time you get it out and put it
away but now I pull it out I press power
zip zap and how long do you go will you
run the battery out of gas no we only
have one room with the vacuum so no one
room with the carpet oh I got it because
we've got the we've got that concrete
floor in there and the hardwood floor so
you end up with these little kind of
dust bunnies so when I say you don't bat
we don't vacuum like if you don't vacuum
with carpet you don't really notice it
well I do because I'm nuts maybe yeah
you're nuts a little bit but we use a
swiffer for the other parts of the of
the house you get that nice Swiffer my
wife is such an environmentalist that
the idea of using a swiffer and then you
know having to throw away the the
swiffer rag or whatever you told I would
drive her even that that's too much
that's too much yeah and so you as a
weak spineless man just go along with
that I'm so grateful to her for having
sex with me I get it to you know I don't
I don't even think of it as spineless I
think it was a voluntary tax that I pay
I have not even attack savala a tribute
what did they call it a church tithing
I'm tithing her I've never heard that
word my life really tithing tithing
tithing is I think where you promise
that you're gonna give away a certain
amount of your income to your church or
your charity or whatever Oh tithe you
say tithe ten percent I thought it was
something John bizarre did he does do
that tie thing hahaha that's wordplay j
no that's
that's fun that's good John bizarre as
our friend who likes to go to Amsterdam
is getting a lot of getting a lot of
play today if you're playing at home
yeah well I'd love to see him again he's
good man it's a good man he is a good
guy but you're on the road a lot I am I
go out but not super a lot i go two
weekends a month is usually what i like
to do so so it is so I find if I go more
than that like every once in a while
like in December I've got three weekends
but but oh but the third one is irvine
so that doesn't really count because
i'll be at home right but if i go out of
town three weekends a month and do that
more than just every twice a year i get
nutty you kind of come unglued
untethered from your life and your
friends and you know I also find that
I'm and this is the truth even if I'm
doing just one weekend by the fourth
show I'm bored out of my mind with with
my voice you know here's the thing and
this is what I've been thinking about
lately is I would like I don't mind
doing I don't mind to doing two shows in
places where it's really great and fun
but you know when they're papering the
room and I can still make that I can
still entertain those people and we can
still have a great night me but but it
can it's a little bit of extra work and
it's an it's it's a lot I would love to
be doing almost you know used to be
everybody wanted to do theaters but now
you got people going out doing just
little rooms like they'll go to Denver
or Denver's a bad example because I do
love the club there and I love doing the
whole weekend but they'll go to
someplace like Omaha I don't do one
night instead of the whole weekend just
do just do one night maybe they only
sell a couple hundred tickets but they
get a decent enough chunk of the door
and they're happy the fans are happy
because I feel like one night I could
almost do one show night forever because
good it feels good but I a hundred
percent agree with you but then once
you're doing the two shows a night and
then back to back to shows or three show
the first show feels like the first show
sometimes feels like it's fun now there
I said the second show it's like well I
get it I did this last show but this is
great you're also pretty let's have a
good time wrote and then the third show
it's just like you know I'm lying
I am let's I will tell you this that's
the one thing in my contract that i
don't know i do not do three shows i
refuse to do that third show and it's
the one the two things happen to my
career Jake that I that I've thrown
around any sort of and I'm putting this
in quotes power a the day that I said
I'm not staying in a condo anymore I'm
only staying in a hotel and then be when
I said I'm not doing that third show
anymore and then they'll go well great
well have you do the like let's pretend
at seven nine and eleven well have you
do nine and eleven psych no no you're
misunderstanding I'm not doing 11 I'll
do seven and nine I'm not doing that
midnight show I'm not doing that late
show hmm and what ends up happening is I
don't do that show but i still sit and
watch it and then get angry that i
didn't do the show because i'm still
there why am I not making the matter
that has happened to me that has
happened to me yeah and I feel and
sometimes even when it's like I go to
st. Louis and the third show in st.
Louis that place you know what I'm
talking about as I do a funny bone in
westport I've never worked there but I
know it oh really never I could have
sworn that there were people who told me
how much they like to uh I believe the
guy the books it is a fan yeah but I've
never worked there hmm well they they
they allowed smoking like they were the
poor way too long way too and that's why
I never were yes and the third show if
you did that Saturday and you did three
the third show first of all it starts at
midnight and has to be done by 120 so
when I say it starts at midnight starts
really at 12 10 so it's a it's a kind of
a short right but everybody they don't
care because they're a little bit loaded
and you just go up and you do the thing
but even though it's sort of a weird
experience doing it the idea that you've
done the whole night and then you're
gonna stop and then you're watching that
show it's just like tease now I can't
say that I did this I want to be able to
do it so that i can say that did it and
then then as you say to be you want to
get paid I I also then part of me also
even though I like and I stand I but I
Stay I kind of stay and watch that third
show because something feels weird to me
about just going alright see you guys
and they're still doing a show and I'm
going back to the hotel being done
there's something in my head that
doesn't flip like I feel like I should
be there even if I'm refusing to perform
if that makes sense Emily does
well if it's the same two guys going on
first as before yeah then every like you
feel like oh I should be part of watch
apart you guys we're best friends this
week yeah I think we're weird we're
friends you don't still do tuesday
through right you just go nobody no
clubs don't do tuesday through but i'll
do i'll do i'll do wednesday thursday
friday saturday you will or sometimes
I'll do thursday friday saturday sunday
but a lot of them now it's like thursday
friday saturday yeah that's it that's
enough and i'm actually loving this new
trend that's happening in a lot of
cities is one show friday and then to
saturday yeah well i would like that too
and i would like to i would like to
start doing less of these places where
they paper the room and they and nobody
you know because they the club owners
sort of don't really care about you that
much either they act like well these
people are in for free what do i owe you
it's like well I'm the reason that they
came you know if you don't want to pay
me to do a show for them then get
someone in to do that show and I'll do
the show we have all the paid people go
in this room and I'll do a show for them
and then all the other free people go in
that room and you get someone to do a
free show for them for free yeah and
then we'll see next week how many people
are in my room and how many people are
in your room you know but that's just a
cranky old Goodwin I'm very concerned
for you in this setting do you think you
win that fight oh I don't think they
would even let it happen someone else to
do it probably right but what I'm saying
no I I what i'm saying is i'd rather go
in I'm thinking of here's what here's if
it's too bad they're doing 7 9 and 11
because if they were just doing 9 and 11
shows yes I would do the seven o'clock
sure i'll just come in i'll be the seven
o'clock guy all week i would love right
yeah i'll just do my one show at seven
and love it or even five Five's probably
too early too early maybe in a few more
years how old are people before they'll
come to a five o'clock show 64 no 75 I
bet you can get some 40 year old people
to come to a five o'clock show I you
know I do my podcast up and sketch fest
every year we did not go last year for
scheduling purposes silly reasons but we
do 11 o'clock in the morning on saturday
I started choosing that time because I
said you know nobody else is doing a
show at eleven in the morning at this
festival and these festival-goers have
nothing else to do their thirties biding
their time all afternoon waiting for the
shows at night let's do an eleven
o'clock in the morning podcast and it's
fantastic so you're
people will come so you get to take
advantage of your fans boom and you also
get to take advantage of the people who
are just somebody else's fans who got
nothing to do right they got none else
to do hey let's go check that out at
eleven o'clock yeah we get them they
come and their fans and then then they
talk to people and we're doing a shampoo
commercial was that shampoo they gave i
think it is there was not a shampoo they
tell two friends and they tell two
friends in the new shampoo wash that I
don't know it wasn't the remember the
what was the name of the one that's got
beer in it but don't drink it remember
that one I do but what was it it wasn't
brewmaster shampoo no sir there was no
prude master uh did you ever hear die
that album by Dice Clay the the day
though laughter died it was his
follow-up to his huge album know and
it's embalming basically I think it's at
The Comedy Store know somewhere in a
gate on an album worry buddy song he's
bombing miserably and but he does this
whole riff about shampoos and about
about and I'm gonna get some of the
beats wrong but about how pert is more
expensive than Jehovah and he's doing
that dice delivery huh so I want to use
perked and it's this painfully unfunny
bit that was mix makes me laugh because
he's committed to selling this hoard
like it's like he just didn't know who
he was after that special the first one
will because I think he had all he had a
ton of that material for that specific
character I think that was one character
that he was doing in a bigger kind of
show yeah kind of took over and became
the thing the other thing that happened
with him is I think he would start that
was a satire but then all at once he had
some people who were coming because it
was a satire and some people were coming
because this is no that's this is my
leader yeah bro that I lives there
always that's this is how we're all want
to be yeah frat dudes and that'll mess
up your head and I and I think then I
think he stir and I don't know him prior
to this uh I then think he started
believing that character and he started
living his life as that character oh
that could have had I think so I think
so he sold out the big medicine school
he did too he did and our French Steve
Martin did our friend Dane Cook did our
friend Louie CK sold it out we secrets
in rosso to Kevin Hart
Kevin Hart I who I think it's very funny
by the way I think he's terrific too I
never heard of the guy and I heard he's
doing three nights at the staple center
there's like three years ago in arenas
know what well but that's because you
come up in the he came up as the black
comedy world I mean that's a very
supportive kind of scene once you get
established there you go hey I never
heard I was in Chicago at the same exact
time is Bernie Mac and I'd never heard
of bernie mac and but yet i'm told you
know at the time just like what we're
gonna go see Bernie Mac he's selling out
the theaters like I don't even I'm in
comedy and I don't know this guy well
the weird thing to me about it well now
I'm sure Kevin Hart has a huge crossover
of course but but like a guy like
earthquake who's been around forever who
I could be like man earth earthquake or
Dino Don DC Korea's I know the name that
guy is these guys should be huge
crossover mainstream stars in my opinion
okay go you go to watch earthquakes
shown it's like minutes like eighty
percent black audience and I'm like why
aren't there more why aren't there more
white people in here this guy it's not
like he's doing some humor that you
can't write if you're not black it's
like Jesus I it's it's very confusing
but but yeah I don't I don't know what
it'd be like though to be a guy who's
selling out an arena sure it's great it
feels good in your wallet it feels good
in your pants how would the show be
what's it like on stage yeah that's what
I'm saying i mean III know you got
closer to greek when you're doing the
show that big right well that's somebody
else's fans but yeah you feel i would
say yeah i can say i can testify that
when you're doing a crowd that big it's
it's not the same kind of really
connected feeling that you get and I've
250-seat you're kinda just talk you're
performing right yeah that's all the
communicate kind of like this is when I
say this and this is how they usually
react any I can kind of hear that
general or me consensus that people
enjoyed that joke and now it feels like
it's time to say the next joke ah you
know so it doesn't you almost have to do
you show a bunch of times in a smaller
place to kind of get to see how it works
so that then when you go to that giant
room like if you only performed in
places that were eight thousand seats I
don't know what you're
show would be ridiculous well there was
it doesn't Regan do that on a regular
basis isn't he like 6,000 seats is he
but does he does he work on his act in
smaller places maybe just maybe he's the
exception of that maybe he's the guy who
makes it but he was always big but what
he does i guess on sage a theater makes
sense because he was big in a club you
know those gestures the ACT outs the the
vocal gymnastics he's a showman he's
great he's I stand by T's why he's one
of the best of what we do oh yeah i
would go watch his show in a second
absolutely in a sec we used to go in
Chicago when Brian re going to come and
and you were you were one of these guys
would do this to I believe you you
worked the improv in Chicago not the
funny firm or just rising star no I was
at the improv he was not the improv but
then they got into a thing they did this
incentive thing with their managers for
what cuz they they were like the more
people if you can get more people in
here we're gonna pay you more based on
that and so they would just paper the
crap out of it and so sometimes and then
the doorstep it was so terrible in the
room at the door staff you know the
bouncer the people who were supposed to
tell people to shut up they wouldn't
even go in there because they couldn't
deal with a couldn't even they couldn't
handle the kind of push back they'd gate
was that room the improv went from being
a great hot room uh to being awful fast
because what you just said it was like
trying to do a comedy show at a football
like there's gonna be a football game
but now you but further comedy here's
Comedy yeah but they would compete with
the funny firm uh-uh and we would be
working the other rooms in town you know
the the comics and so we would either
when we were done with our shows both
the improv and the funny room had a late
show or they had a sunday show and we
would go to see the guys like you at the
improv or guys like Brian Regan or Bill
Hicks at the funny firm and I don't know
what my point was but my point was we
become a watch Brian Regan Wow a long
way to go was a good story he was a guy
I think you were saying he was a guy who
if you were in if you were a local comic
in the town and he came to town you
would go see you go see but it's always
flattering as a comic when you see other
comics Oh
that aren't in the show well you get
that too and I and I get it now on the
road like wherever I go it's like and I
remember I did this this is funny I
remember taking I specifically took a
weekend off it was from my birthday in
1990 and I took the weekend off Jimmy
what's I that's 25 years I know but
here's what I did I remember I took it
off because I wanted to see Kevin amini
I wanted to see kevin meaney live and if
I was didn't take the weekend off I
wouldn't be able to see him so I took
him off my girlfriend of the time
jennifer and I went to see kevin meaney
and then afterwards uh it was very
important for me that he knows i'm a
comedian he's got to know he's boy he's
got to know I took the weekend off to
see him I don't know if anybody comes up
to me and says they're a comedian there
a fan I always tell them you know that
could that is that doesn't mean
something to me to have somebody who
wait whether they're an open mic ER or
they're a guy who's headlining in
whatever it means something because they
know what it's like to be on stage and
they appreciate what you did so i would
say that on and always wish them good
luck I'm very flattered I in me and when
they come to watch me but I guess what
the hell again was my point though I do
want to be very clear in case young
comments or listen to this I more than
it flatters the hell out of me when I'll
look in the back of the comedy club and
there's you know six guys sitting around
a table like I go to go bananas go
bananas in Cincinnati comics will drive
from Columbus or indie or whatever to
come to watch me there and then it's
like it just blows my mind it's like
there's nothing better is it nice there
go bananas you've never been there no oh
I recorded my album nerd said my top
three clubs in the country I've let
myself down I've let my I told you I
still haven't called the guy and well
you blew that that's the best club in
the country I know well I'm gonna call
him but I don't know why I don't know
what's wrong with me I don't know what's
wrong with me I literally don't know
you're not a good businessman that's
true that it okay so i dunno what's I've
known that for a while you um you should
do that you should do bananas there's so
many why am I telling you the great jet
you know what I'm nine times I'm utterly
important and and I was asking him
because because there's a lot of places
that I've been working over the years
where they were they like me or where
they're gonna
they're gonna pay me and it's like my
calendar is full so I haven't gone to
search out some of these places right
now now it's like like I said I'm not so
crazy about doing the room where it's
full all week but you got to kind of
hose them down first to get them
organized wouldn't send you there I
would send you to know like so that I
don't do those clubs that's what I'm
saying is I'm now looking to go back and
do some of these little artisanal jewel
boxes of the no nobody's happy with that
yeah no that's not good let me ask you
this when you saw my Cincinnati nothing
Cincinnati you could take artisanal and
get right back on the plane would have
taken you at pietros could go and double
down now let me ask when you saw Todd
glass of the airport was he telling them
how they could be doing it better was he
do you know the stories about Todd and
comedy club ya know and he likes to get
he likes he's ready to recruit you like
if you don't agree with what thinks they
should be doing yeah then that's a thing
like most of the subtext of my
conversations with Todd's like Jake we
all know we all know that what they
should be doing they should have a
candle and not a big candle a small
candle and when the candles are too big
one time I got into it with judah
friedlander about he wanted to we're all
gonna sign a petition to STOP the check
drop I signed that petition I signed it
why not sign it how about let's all sign
a petition for them to tell the drunk
guy to shut the hell up well that's the
petition that's always I mean I feel
like the check drop is such a my thing
is like are you okay did you hear that
no is that the c diff no it's not the
seat up the signal although she did kind
of come back the other day but I'm okay
okay uh I feel fecal transplant that was
one of the options if it didn't improve
they say that can turn it around yes I'm
not doing that until like it's necessary
I don't think you can do it to yourself
another person does it to you know so
you have to do it at home okay I was
gonna do it we can be done at home but
you need to help her I was used the cats
I was gonna use the cats a big mistake
really big no I disagree hats cats have
got this virus in their boot I think
that can be right cleans your it out no
gets in there clean jojic it can make
you crazy can make it crazy pregnant
ladies are not even allowed to handle
this i know all this okay right now
you've got a kid [ __ ] i understand it
this is like you know you're trying to
tell somebody something that you feel
like is important
mation and they act like you're calling
them stupid this is my this my wife gets
into me with this all the time it says
like no I don't know all the things that
you know so I'm trying to tell this is
an interesting fact you also think it's
an interesting fact but you think it's
become less interesting because you
think everybody knows it I don't think
everybody thank you everybody does know
that I certainly do about cat poop and
the neurological using not good bring
the ladies can't look at it no they
can't even go past mm-hmm anyway where
were we do you remember nope wait ugh
last 20 the check drop yeah I don't
understand it it's it's it's a it's a
holdover from the old blues or jazz club
days and makes no sense it's the only
theater experience that you go to where
it is interrupted yes fight them asking
things you get that the worst is when
they SWAT team it when all the
waitresses are in the back then they got
each got all their 10 tables and they
all leave the back at the same time and
boom boom boom hit everybody he had a
stagger at at least at least stay I
think most clubs have come around to the
stagger or pay-as-you-go how about that
do something do anything but what's
happening because what a good headliner
would keep their attention I shouldn't
have to it's an art I'm doing an art
form up there yeah i'm not i'm not some
busker a good waitress wouldn't realize
that we're on the same no it's good i
like it a good headliner who was the
person who's saying that to you I don't
like that oh you know what is old school
it's always a guy who was never that
great of a headliner but he wants to
convince you that he does he can handle
the check drop but you're right it is
old school good landlord who could light
a headliner could follow anything and
you can handle the check drop yeah but I
don't want to have to follow an act
that's doing something that doesn't set
me up properly doesn't mean I'm not a
good a headliner just mean it's not the
right setup for me well yeah there's
plenty of good Johnny Mathis doesn't
have a guy come out ahead of him and
swallow fire and stuff does he was a bad
example it's better now because he does
do that niche they've been touring
together for 35 years who's that mister
lift Oh guy the guy who picks things up
with a piercing nipples and scrotum and
stuff Johnny Mathis doesn't have that
guy open up for him he also doesn't have
Jerry Vale open forum you know I mean he
wouldn't follow him same thing with the
same thing
so it doesn't mean the Johnny Mathis
isn't a great vocalist not one could
argue he's not but that's not that what
we're talking about here nothing much
yes talent we're talking but he's maybe
a terrible example because he's so the
three generations older than the only
people who could get the Johnny Mathis
thing are people who don't even know you
got to sit them it's going to be an all
day just to get them understand what a
podcast is you know they're never going
to be able to listen to this so i
apologize to you young people about
Johnny Mathis listen if it can we Justin
Bieber can we take it down well what's
the name Taylor Swift who would Taylor
Swift not have open for her uh Sheryl
Crow they're both headliners I can't
even tell what you're thinking now I'm
not a fan of one of those acts now
listen and not like to bad-mouth anybody
but the point is this did you have a bad
experience uh no I have she had a very
nice experience with her uh really but
I'm not a fan of her music I don't like
her music ok show crow we're speaking of
butts you but she spent a great night
somewhere I she helped me with a pilot
that I did for vh1 and she was very
accommodating very helpful and very
pleasant mm-hmm so it pains me that I'm
not a fan of her music no because she
was very very friend but you just can't
be it's not your thing tell me back what
is your thing what is your musical do
you mean by that what kind of meat you
do it sounds like are you an ac/dc guy
or so I don't just like ac/dc but I
don't think they should all aim Dodger
Stadium was too big of the venue um to
but that goes back to the thing that we
were talking about before it's like
Madison Square Garden is too big of a
venue for stand-up comedy but what's
Kevin Hart going to do a million years
in a in the comedy cellar is he just
gonna be there all night until everyone
I or comes to see and I you know I get
it but I
those stadiums are too big to see music
and again you know my favorite band of
all time of Chicago the rock band
Chicago rock rock is in quotes yeah
through my favorite saturday in the park
yeah it's great song off chicago 5 1972
uh Iron Maiden those those two are not
similar pretty weird right yeah I just
saw Chris de Burgh last week love him
like a singer songwriter named Ellis
Paul I've never eaten his Iron Maiden
the guy we're one of them's a pilot
bruce dickinson the lead singers a pilot
as well yeah he said not not just a part
not not not like Scientology mr.
Scientology's a pilot john travolt not
like he's no no he's saying this guy is
a pilot like welcome thank you for
flying united he could do that yes he
basically just flies the Iron Maiden jet
but I think he was doing that before
Iron Maiden took off no no no okay I
think he got license while he was with
Iron Maiden so that he could fly their
tour I think that's why he did it I
think I think was a money-saving uh yeah
boy you bet that much that feels weird
in the backstage after party of the show
you see that guy hitting it hard yeah
and you're like hey bruce come on slow
now baby you're gonna defy the jet man
high on your wings ah that's my bruce
dickinson impression i love them gonna
see them in March when they come to the
Great Western forum it's not called that
anymore but i'll be going there mm-hmm
and uh I like all sir dad like
everything not everything that's not
true there's stuff I don't like no
Sheryl Crow don't k don't like I'm not a
fan not a fan of her music don't like
don't like Kravitz don't Lenny Kravitz I
don't like Lenny Kravitz he seems to me
to be a just a little too high on his
own supply you know what I mean these
poser I'm not a fan at all I wouldn't
say I don't know if I would go as far as
the sake book I just feel like I just
feel like you know you don't you could
wear shirts sometimes you I don't you
yes you want to take your shirt off if
you had abs like that would you worship
would you ever wear a shirt I don't know
if I would if I look are you kidding me
i would take my shirt off from time to
time but once everybody knew
what I look like with my shirt off I
wouldn't have to kind of keep it yep
still got him but he is a rock star
looking by roger daltrey back the
Woodstock look at Bobby plant looks
ronde have you seen Roger Daltrey lately
yeah I just saw the three shirts on I
know I just saw the who last I saw the
who last year this year in New Orleans
at jazz fest yes and then I saw Roger
Daltrey i did a corporate cape for
hewlett-packard and he played at the end
of the night he was the entertainment
and he starts his show with his shirt
you know the top button is obviously
unbuttoned but then he's got one or two
more unbuttoned okay and then as the
night goes on another button goes down
like you're listening to him your love
in the show you turn to your friends how
many goes to get a beer you cook you
look the next time you look he's got
another button button until the shirts
completely open and then the shirts
completely opened and then you turn
around and now he's got his shirt off
and he's windmilling the mic he still
takes his shirt off he does yeah I still
70 yeah is he 71 I don't know he stays
up there he takes his shirt off and then
I from Earth Wind and Fire that guy's
got a shirt or Dean white bass player
who ever which were the guys who takes
his shirt off he's got his shirt off he
looks he's very slim he said for Dean
white cuz everybody else in that band is
uh not that fit Oh or they're young ya
know that's what baylee's kid is in that
bag now yeah this is one of the older
dudes he'd the guy based it's all
positive he looks a little like a
skeleton country guy yeah for being
white he's got his says yeah he's got
his shirt off he's not i did that i like
when you get to be 70 sun's out guns out
I'm fine with that but when you're I'm
laughing you use that expression you
know that one right I didn't I've never
heard it so right now and it may be
laughs like I'm a child hearing it for
the first thing good the first time I
heard it I was on guns out of TIA love
it I just saw her throne if i open up
for chicago at the forum and they were
fantastic as west chicago mm-hmm so but
he kept his shirt on this particular
evening you know why roof know so yeah
maybe that's it yeah that's it he does
go by the sun's out guns out not not um
oh god this is like the old guy festival
roger daltrey not roger daltrey it can
be at night doesn't matter him they were
taking it off taking his shirt off the
show starts with a shirt on and it gets
on but that's how he knows he's done he
doesn't know do you want a light he goes
no I got a shirt yeah he sees her when
it son dia every other song every other
song everyone in a button once I got my
shirt off anytime I couldn't close a
long time uh did you speak with him did
you get to spend some time with me I got
my picture taken with him but I didn't
get to it was one of those things where
you know the mucky-mucks there's a meet
and greet ya ever done a corporate thing
where there's a meeting graph done it
when I'm the guy meeting and greeting
but when Roger Daltrey's a guy meeting
and greeting you know they pony dup yeah
and he's and he's doing it everybody got
a really nice photo with him but you
don't you stand next to him you look at
the camera you make sure you smile
because they're taking the picture
whatever you're doing that's your
picture with Roger Daltrey because
there's another person coming anyway
right so I didn't get to talk to him I
saw him once at the CBS radford lot in
studio city california and i was walking
out and figured I when I was auditioning
for I was the audition for a situation
comedy and and he was going in to
audition for something as well where do
you think that I kind of love it I
couldn't be like and brother maybe
wasn't auditioning maybe he was just
going in for a meeting or something but
it seemed to me like he was going in
maybe to meet about a role you don't ask
him to audition was he's looking at he
have a bunch did he have paper in his
hands and what know what he did was he
kind of mumbling things look at the
paper to look up in the air rehearsing
its allies he was pacing back and forth
but I remember walking past him and
going well that couldn't be that can't
possibly why would wholly it is it's
Roger Daltrey mm-hmm and when you
whenever you see somebody out of context
like that i'm a it still kind of blows
my mind like a dumb hayseed like I don't
understand show well and he's got
glasses he wears glasses those those
plenty this little tailor glasses yeah
this one I want to call this a 1900 in
let's call this 99 that was a lie that
was a good time for you turn of the
century yeah turn of the century what
was happening we were alive at the turn
of the century that's ridiculous we were
calling at the turn of the century in
2001 but now snow [ __ ] right it was
there's people getting ready to go to
high school who were not alive then
think about that yeah anybody
now I do think about it they were boy it
was it 1994 right and they could just
start drinking now that's 21 years ago
yeah uh right before we were already
done done done with what I bid our
careers were a party on the downside I
was underway no 94 was still a good time
for me you're doing okay were you
wearing the green suits what was
happening in 94 uh I have the bolo what
was I was going out I was still wearing
some cookie I was kookier I don't know I
still were some weird things but 94 was
still there was a possibly you know at
this point I hold out the hope that Kyle
Kinane will get a television show and
I'll get to be his neighbor something
like that that's that's the dream now I
don't know why I threw Kyle out but
that's you know things happen I think
he's very funny funny he's doing what I
want to do he's traveling around and
doing these one-nighter in these venues
looks like fun looks what looks like fun
what he's doing yeah I I don't he might
be a little more party may party man
than I i think is uh I you know what I
don't trust I don't trust that i would
sell enough tickets to i think i'd have
to do like a week I'd have to just leave
on a Monday and just do it like a bus
tour yeah sure and hope that i recoup to
the money that I would want to uh I
would hate to show up somewhere and have
60 people sitting there it would bump me
up what if it was 150 people that'd be
fine happy with that yeah you know I
charge 75 bucks a ticket so that would
work out very well that's fine right
that's fine you get a free shirt without
her as a haircut would the audience
members yeah well they could they get
the the entertainment they don't get a
souvenir out of the deal yeah Greg and I
want to do is show where we give each
other it will get in we give the
audience members haircut yeah this guy's
obsession with giving haircuts now is
something that I have to talk to him
about and sit him down seriously no we
[ __ ] well he's more into he's deeper
into tonight than I am you also want to
do this work I cut my own hair care I
cut my own hair that maybe you didn't
know that about I could tell for years
yeah no you did not Utah well this
haircuts a little bit weird now what
about the old days when you and I give
here if you're a guy that lines up your
head shots from 85 once you start 85 I
start an 82 my first time on stage
natura and then yeah and then I won in
high school no I was just 20 I was 21
you're born in 1961
940 1960 seriously yes you look great I
feel great thank you look that's very
nice ray to your 55 years old yes yes I
you know what I credit you know what I
credit the blood of my victims about dr.
David Williams I just like to bring
around to the serial killer thing that's
for you that's for you Jimmy let me I'm
fasten about this and I'm gonna tell you
something it makes me feel better about
a lot of the things in my career you all
right yeah I'm okay it could be it's
good here the immune system it builds it
up uh I assumed we were the same age and
it infuriated me jealousy admittedly all
jealousy that you were so successful and
wonderful and I was just still
struggling and trying to get by now
granted you were a thousand times
funnier than I was back in the late 80s
Early 90s but I still was like this
guy's like my same age why is he do so
much better than me what year did you
start uh standing up comedy yeah 88 so
you started six years yeah as I'm six
years younger than you okay see well
there you go well I wait I'm 42 so I'm
like what were you shaking i'm 13 years
younger you mean i have to say my real
age but then you don't say you're really
well my my running joke these days is
that whenever i would say my real age
nobody would believe me they would
always go out well i think you're 40 and
enough people feel younger yeah they're
going here well that's how I feel like
when I tell people my age I'm lying I
feel like that can't be true but it is
true well you don't look for the end and
so I enough people told me you don't
look your age stop saying you are and so
I joke me and my podcast started saying
that I was 41 and then I just had a
birthday so I've turned 42 these are my
fans know me isn't being 42 but we all
know what I really am when I well first
of all thank you because I'm flattered
that you think that there's enough
people listening to this that it matters
how old you say you are well my fans
listen to this yes well and thank you
thank you new listeners for welcome for
the part Obama on behalf of them I thank
you for the part o bump I look forward
to you your
listening disappointedly to next week's
haha you don't guest on every week no no
sometimes it's just you sometimes it's
just me and then sometimes it's my wife
and I it started off a lot of the
episodes were me in this friend of mine
Nigel Lawrence do you know him I don't
he's a very funny comic from Canada and
you know younger than he's in his
mid-30s and he was living right out near
here and we were friends and I was
trying to figure out how to do
podcasting and he was a guy who would
come over and talk to me all right but
that was but see I missed out because I
haven't been in the scene in LA with all
you guys like I've never met TIG Notaro
I wish I had met TIG Notaro because I
think she's so funny she's great and I
will meet her one of these days but I
wasn't in that scene so I didn't know
like I went on Marc Maron's podcast and
I didn't even barely knew what a podcast
was you know and then I was trying to
figure out cuz it's such a fun it's a
fun thing to do cuz you own it it's a
thing that you're doing that's your
thing let me ask you a question I know
this is your program but i but i had to
ask you a question go ahead why what you
just brought up actually interests me
you're a guy that we all now you started
six years before me so i could say this
comfortably that we all looked up to the
great Jake Johansen but yet we didn't
ever see you hanging around the improv
or hanging around egg bees or hanging
around uh well those really the only two
places i would go to uh why was that why
were you not ever well our to the scene
where as other guys were you know over
10 or gary laser or other people like
this from your generation would hang out
Scott larose Paul Provenza uh-huh I let
me those are all great names wait men I
when I first moved to town in 87 i lived
over near Julia Sweeney was my neighbor
we lived in the same building and that
was on sierra bonita over near melrose
so i could have actually walked to the
improv from there that have been a mile
and a half but when i first came to town
i had these managers mora brezner and
Steinberg they had Letterman and Robin
Williams and Billy Crystal and Woody
Allen and you know they were big deal
and their thing was
we're gonna you're not gonna be people
are gonna be seeing you in town all the
time and I was ok with that because I
was working on the road enough doing
enough shows that I was generating new
material and I just wasn't going up that
much and and then then i moved here in
Santa Monica because I every time i left
my house over there i was in a traffic
jam and it was kind of affecting my mood
in my and i wasn't doing a ton of sets
and i wasn't part of a cool scene so it
wouldn't be like oh I gotta move to
silverlake because that's where that's
where my peeps are and that's where the
fun shows are I mean I understood that
that scene was starting to happen but I
moved out here and I love being by the
beach and I made friends out here and
this is mike so now when i come back
into town I I got a wife I get a kid or
even before then I'd be I'd be out two
weeks I'd come home I want to hang out
with my friends and I just didn't again
wants to drive across town and do a set
were you not getting paid I'm now I love
to do it because it's like oh I'm seeing
you or I'm seeing greg behrendt or
there's hey Doug Benson or you know Doug
invited me to be on his podcast at the
nerdmelt and I'm like yeah can't wait
yeah wait to go do that go talk about
movies yeah so now I love to I love to
go out and do that stuff but I just
wasn't around then first it was
deliberately some kind of weird strategy
based on my did that payoff managers you
tell me Jimmy um look here here in my
skin my my was [ __ ] me to say inside
might I meant it to be Dickie yet it
came off dicker that I wanted to be I
admit that I think I didn't really
realize that because you know I'm doing
Letterman every year I'm doing a special
here or there I'm doing my own thing I
didn't kind of realize like if you're
not going up and doing sets of these
little rooms and people aren't seeing
you and you're not part of their thing
then they forget about you you know they
don't realize look I'm writing a new
hour of material every couple years i'm
doing a great Letterman thing I got the
respect to my peers and I'm friends with
all the guys you know that are coming up
that are great and but I so I do think
that not having done those sets around
town might have might have kept me from
getting some things knows what it is but
I did I did have a lot of fun
how to surf I spent a lot of days you
know when you kind of think about your
life this is another thing I like to
talk about is do you like your
definition of success and I think it has
to do with your time like how much time
have you had to enjoy yourself so i've
been surfing I've been hanging out at
the beach I've been I've been doing some
fun stuff so how about you take you for
your time how about you ah yeah it's not
gonna go any further that's my favorite
euphemism the show business thing like
hey whatever happened to that game show
that I auditioned for yeah that's not to
go any further yeah that's then here's a
fresh using show business lingo by very
first audition an observing it was right
first audition having had an agent it
was for an empty yeah for an MTV game
show and in the in the description it
said host should be a Sinbad type
entertainer ba ba ba ba ba ba so I said
in the and again I'm stupid thinking
that we all talk like human beings she I
said uh I said hey it says here that you
guys are looking for a Sinbad type I'm
not so sure I fit that in she goes yeah
we're going a different direction than
that I go oh are you going a different
direction hey I said it like that I did
and then now addresses are like wooden
yes all I was why are you kidding me you
you just amateur like I came off so
green and so I didn't understand
anything and are you going to direction
so horrible well it just seems a little
sarcastic but but also justified as a
comedian I support that and you're like
why did you put why did you say like all
I have to go on when I'm coming in here
to get ready to be part of this thing is
that you're looking for a sin debt
Sinbad type and then I get in the room
and you go you're going in a different
direction that how does that help me how
does okay anything but Sinbad so it's
anything with that then which by the way
I think we all know how hard it is to
print up a new piece of paper but that's
literally they could have just taken
that off that piece of paper well and
also we're looking for a Sinbad type and
anything but Sinbad those are the
opposite of each
other so when you tell someone to come
in and get ready to be something now I
prepared for exactly what you don't want
for that that's good right except I'm
not black yeah I didn't I just did you
get it how'd that go I was great I've it
Akane first six easy uh no it was you it
was they as soon as I said that it was
over the walls came by I just saw them
shut down and you know it was one of the
thing where you think you think you're
gonna be if Erica it's gonna be funny
and that it doesn't land funny and it
just lands like like like again I looked
like it I just looks like such like the
girl just off the bus in a poison video
you know it's like that's what I looked
like and and then they shut down and it
was over it was over yeah that's a
toughy man was probably some dumb TV
show on MTV that never got made or who
knows but still you've they're all those
little heart aches things that you
didn't get we're good get in the car and
you feel like crap you're like oh then
he's like I should have said that no you
weren't gonna get it anyway that didn't
help but certainly will it be one thing
if it was a thing that you know it went
on to be and that was family feud or
something right yeah and you'd then
you'd be a little bummed out but we
don't eat you don't even remember what
it was yeah do you still audition for a
lot of stuff you know having worked at
Conan for the last six years uh I wasn't
audition for anything so i have not
auditioned for anything in six years
anything that i'd done on TV has been an
offer that's great and uh but i just did
tell my manager today like hey if any
game shows whatever come up but you know
let's throw my head back in the ring to
audition because i've been creating my
own stuff and I've been doing uh pilots
every year so I've always been the last
couple years I've been under contract
for my own show oh that's great so and
then I hosting a show on science channel
called race to escape at the moment
which was offered to me and it was the
greatest feeling in the world what is it
oh geez Jake is this I apologize but as
you know show business is bad well
there's four million channel its vast so
it is the greatest I'm so proud to be
hosting the show it's called race to
escape a guy named Ria's Patel created
it it's on science channel Ria's Patel
that's his name
ra AZ p atl we as Ria's Patel hmm
foreign yeah is this show that's what I
was going to say is this show is this a
show is there another host of it in
another place that now you are they boys
or the American version of that I don't
believe so I fact i think the hope is
that we can go so you're the original
host on the original houghton race to
escape and but it's hosted in india by a
guy with another name pageant at some
point it will be yeah uh here's the deal
you got to I these escape rooms which
are very popular right now what is an
escape room you don't even know this I
know what a safe room is but this seems
like the opposite of it yes okay the
shape room is where you and me and the
third friend can all go and we each
spend 50 bucks and they lock you in a
room and you have an hour to figure out
these clues and stuff to get out of the
room mm-hmm riaz came up with a way to
make that into a TV show where it's a
challenge there's two identically
prepared rooms two teams of three that
they are not only racing against the
clock they have to get out of the room
before the other team does so you have
to solve these five clues to get out
before the other team as well as before
time is up and if not oh you win
twenty-five thousand dollars and the
losers get sawed in half yeah or tiger
different every week well we mix it up
just so the viewer knows to look for
something to at the end of the show yeah
and I'm hands-on with the murders I'm
hands-on if it saw it in half I run the
bandsaw yeah burned alive you like the
matter what happened yet and I'm afraid
of fires that was that was a tough way
it's big III lift the door for the caged
Tiger runs out more than happy to do it
who's the serial killer now that's the
name of my show well that's probably
tighter riaz and see if we can pitch
that around with you but it's great show
and I'm proud of it but I have not been
auditioning for anything because of it
because I've had something going on yeah
you don't go to you know who who you got
a job you don't need to audition for a
job because you have a job you've got to
Joe you got three jobs you've got your
doing the conan thing which how do
that's warm up aw I don't do that
anymore i left that in February when
race to escape started okay so what do
you do a Kona now uh just guess I'm get
on the deal
so I'm busy creating with them and I do
remotes and I do whatever they need me
to do I'm not basically under kind I'm
still under contract with them I just
don't do the warm-up anymore okay so I
bake I'll do with it they called me
tonight and said hey get over here we
need you to do the stupid sketch I'm
there this partially explains then why
you were to come do this because I
remember when we were talking two years
ago you were pretty like it has to be on
your route it had to be right yeah
where's now it's a little more open so
uh yeah I travel I have the podcast I
still have the kind of thing I've raced
to escape um and my wife can get my son
she's gonna pick up my son it turns out
okay good um are we done we don't we
don't have to go too much longer
whatever you want to do I can shop all
day with you the podcast is called to
the what is it cold all I want to do is
all i can think now is podcast the
podcast cuz you call it the part cast
but it's so we don't we go park casteth
on is our annual event that we do to
raise money for Smile Train we do have
podcast com that's an accurate statement
yeah it's called never not funny never
not funny and I knew that and I couldn't
think of was all right listen I don't
know the name of this just Jake Jake
this mmm here's the thing Jake johane
take calm at the time that I was looking
was taken I couldn't get Jake calm and
the guy he's some had a fishing charter
somewhere and he was like it's gonna be
yeah you can have it for ten thousand
dollars and i said i don't i'm not gonna
pay you ten thousand dollars so then i
could have got Jake Johansen calm but
how do you spell johansson well there's
a lot of different ways different ways
no wrong and so I thought and I thought
and I decided I thought about talking
monkey calm but at the time this is 1994
Joe Rogan own talking monkey com do you
really yeah I was very funny because I
thought I want to get talking monkey got
calm and I go online it because it's
owned I go who don't let ya Joe Rogan um
and so so then it's Jake histo you
didn't want to wrestle him for the
rights to that name I didn't even think
of asking about that as a possibility
but you know until knowing what I know
now no I wouldn't want to wrestle no of
course I got this off his website though
the giant gorilla kettlebell just your
dumbfounded I don't even I react to it
I'm just saying I don't buy everything
off of amazon i buy some things from on
it calm they're not a sponsor but they
could be so so i just want to say thank
you for coming over and will this be the
last time you'll come over and do it i
don't feel like we did anything so i
could come tomorrow I mean I ok great
I'll do this eight thousand times but it
was fun right did you enjoy the
conversation she did oh we did was talk
yeah was great but I think people enjoy
listening no way they did really they
won't enjoy I don't think so what are
you doing your show that's so much
better than this ring a little bit more
to the table I've been I guess that's
the problem I've only been on it once
that's the only time I just offered to
have you come back on tomorrow you can't
tomorrow did I boy I'll come I'll come
again soon tomorrow is the last chance
yeah okay I couldn't get past the
paywall you know Matt Belknap wait were
you wandering the paywall time yeah
there was a paywall and I you could you
wait a minute you haven't been on in two
years you could only listen to the first
swing 20 minutes and then after that it
was so are you done with that now that's
over oh yeah yeah yeah we're free will
we have two episodes a week we have a
free episode that goes out to you know
are hundreds of thousands of listeners
mm-hmm and then we have our pay one that
goes out to four guys yeah just 75 bucks
a ticket though right well yeah so I
make uh you know yeah that's 300 bucks a
week you gotta split that six ways but I
do this with their four ways so it's all
right it's not bad no but sorry we get
75 bucks each yeah but and then you got
your escape room race to escape I got
that over in science channel yeah it's
you're a busy person not too busy to
come here and chitchat baby no it was
totally worth my time wasn't yeah I
think so this was I think let me tell
you here's where I'm at this was a good
episode haha alright if you want a high
five I like to high-five sometimes at
the end really yeah all right just cuz
you can hear it
well there it is jimmy pardo thank you
Pardo bumpers for following along to the
podcasts I hope you'll be here for
future episodes but then again who can
blame you for doing whatever you do
except for murder and other mean type
crimes of that nature but you can listen
to whatever you want nobody's this isn't
in jail this isn't a jail anyway thanks
for listening I'm Jake I don't forget to
not don't don't for don't give up
there'll be plenty of time to give up
later I say it I've said it there I said
it thanks for listening I gotta go to
Chicago you've got things to do good
luck with that and I'll speak to you
later
you